HEB je spijt van die uitspraak
over die cultuur van De Dood
nee geen enkele spijt
het is 1 cultuur van De Dood
en en wij zijn 1 cultuur van het leven
maar we zijn nu bijna 30.000 palestijnen dood
ja wanneer gaan we het
zionisme bestempel als cultuur van De Dood
nou ZEG uh
ik vind uh dat uh
Israël heeft het recht om te bestaan
binnen veilige grenzen
neem van mij aan de partij van de Albert is altijd
uh 1 land geweest 1 1
1 1 partij van het turisme
1 partij geweest die achter Israel stond
30.000 uh bijna 30.000 doden palestijnen
verder naar jouw uitspraak kom je erop terug zoals je
zoals je weet
pleit ik al heel erg lang voor 1 staart te vuren
en dat zal ik blijven doen
jullie hebben niet
voor emotie gestemd om de militairen samenwerking
definitief te stoppen
waarom niet we hebben wel voor andere emoties
uh in die lijn gestemd
deze toevallig niet
waarom niet en omdat
die emoties bevatten ook
elementen waar we niet mee eens zijn
wat dan Uhm ja dat weet ik niet meer zo uit mijn hoofd